but we've received a statement from the
family they have confirmed the deaths of
Diane and Ron Hughes aged in their 50s
and 60s they'd only been married for 18
months and were in Australia on holidays
from Liverpool the family says that
they're heartbroken are they still
trying to contact family and friends and
they've requested privacy at this
devastating time let's have a listen to
the Queensland Police Commissioner to
find out how that freak accident
happened
what we do know at this very early stage
of the investigation is that one
helicopter was taking off that's had
seven people on board another one coming
into land with six people on board now
they've collided the one helicopter that
was taking off appears its main rotors
have collided with the landing
helicopter
so that first helicopter that was trying
to take off and was in the air it
clipped another helicopter and the first
one ended up crashing to the ground
around 200 300 meters of four people
were killed another three were injured
seriously injured the pilot was killed
he was originally from the UK but had
since made his home and his family in
Australia and an Australian woman who
was up on the Gold Coast on holidays
died as well and she had been on that
helicopter with her nine-year-old son
as for the second helicopter quite a
remarkable recovery there even though
the front of it was all smashed the
glass was cracked and people were
injured inside somehow that helicopter
pilot managed to get it onto the ground
the right way up and all of the
passengers in that helicopter survived
all of this took place in a really busy
a tourist area the Gold Coast an area
where there's normally hundreds of these
flights happening year round as people
go out and take a look at the long
stretches of sandy beaches there we're
in the middle of the tourist season here
so there were lots of people out and
about they saw this crash these
confronting scenes many of them filmed
it as well those helicopters have since
been taken away from The Sandbar the
tide has risen and that area has been
covered in water the big question now
for authorities though is how did this
happen and what can they do to make sure
that that it doesn't happen again
the helicopters took off from a sort of
small landing area it wasn't any major
commercial airport they rely on line of
sight to try and keep out of each
other's way in the air but clearly
something went seriously wrong